-The GOP is facing blowback
for heckling President Biden
during his state of the union
address last night
after he accurately pointed out
that several Republicans
had proposed cutting
Social Security and Medicare.
Meanwhile,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
stood up and shouted
in a fur coat,
like a Real Housewife
who wasn't allowed
into a reunion show.
[ Laughter ]
But, other than that,
Republicans had
a pretty great night.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You might remember that,
after Donald Trump's
rogues' gallery
of dip[bleep] and doofuses
[ Laughter ]
got creamed in the
midterm elections,
the big takeaway for Republicans
was just be normal.
[ Laughter ]
That was basically
their "Clear eyes, full heart,
can't lose."
[ Laughter ]
Trump and his MAGA allies
in the GOP
handpicked a bunch
of ostentatious weirdos,
like vampire enthusiast
Herschel Walker;
[ Laughter ]
Pixar villain Kari Lake;
and Area 51 escapee Dr. Oz,
[ Laughter ]
who campaigned --
campaigned for Senate
in Pennsylvania
by wandering
down the produce aisle,
complaining
about the price of crudité
at a grocery store he called
Wegners,
which does not exist.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the weirdest part
of that video
was always the fact that he
grabbed salsa for a crudité.
Who puts salsa in their crudité?
[ Laughter ]
He's like a college sophomore
putting out hors d'oeuvres
for a date.
[ Baritone ]
Would you like some Funyuns
with your crudité?
[ Laughter ]
Perhaps some Franzia.
I have a January Chardonnay.
That's a very good month.
[ Laughter ]
So, after those candidates lost,
Republicans spent
the next few days
lamenting how weird their party
had gotten
and pleading for Republicans
to just be normal again.
-The Republican Party needs
to do
a really deep introspection look
in the mirror right now,
because this is --
this is an absolute disaster
for the Republican Party.
[ Laughter ]
-We've attracted these
more cartoon characters
and, if somebody speaking
at a rally
with a president
or a presidential candidate
is best known
as a pillow salesman,
[ Laughter ]
run to high heaven.
-Okay, but if that pillow
salesman is Mike Lindell,
it doesn't matter
how far you run --
you will never be out of range
for his voice.
[ Laughter ]
True story -- they say,
if you listen closely,
you can even hear Mike Lindell
screaming about voting machines
when you hold a seashell
up to your ear.
[ Laughter ]
Watch. [Indistinct]
-Get one machine, open it up,
and look in there.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clap ]
-[ Stage whisper ]
You did -- You did great!
[ Laughter ]
Arguably, the first big test
of whether Republicans
could prove they were
a normal governing party was
in the speakership vote
in January,
a test they failed miserably,
after it took 15 rounds
to elect Kevin McCarthy
as their new speaker
and one of their members tried
to physically assault
another one on the House floor,
leaving this infamous photo
of a Republican congressman
being restrained by his face,
so that he couldn't
punch out a colleague.
He looked like he just got
to a house party
and found out there was salsa
in the crudité.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That's an affront to God,
you son of a bitch!"
[ Laughter ]
So, Republicans
failed that test,
but they had a second chance
to make things right
during President Biden's state
of the union address.
All they had to do was sit there
and listen and not be insane.
Just be normal!
[ Laughter ]
Unfortunately,
it seems like some of them
skipped their
electroshock therapy
[ Laughter ]
because they spent
the night heckling
and yelling incoherently
from the back rows,
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who was seen screaming
and pointing fingers
in a white fur coat,
like a Long Island dance mom
about to get her final warning.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Ma'am, how many times do we
have to tell you to sit down?"
[ New York accent ]
How many times do I have
to tell my Kaylie
to get your goshdarn
steps right?!
[ Laughter ]
Why is she wearing
a white fur coat
to the state of the union
address?
She looks like
an old rapper's first wife.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
With that said, it probably
should not have shocked us
that Greene decided to act
like an obnoxious weirdo
at the state of the union,
given that, just a few hours
before the speech,
she posted a video of herself
walking the halls of Congress
while holding
a single white balloon,
in what I'm guessing
was supposed to be
some sort of statement
about Joe Biden's handling
of the suspected
Chinese spy balloon.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at her.
She looks like she threw herself
a Sweet 16 party
and no one showed up.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ]
Maybe everybody went
to the other Shakey's.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Biden did give them plenty
of opportunities to be normal.
He ticked through a series
of what should've been
bipartisan applause lines,
but the new Republican speaker
of the House, Kevin McCarthy,
sitting behind Biden
for the first time,
made a show of refusing
to stand or applaud.
In fact, McCarthy couldn't
even bring himself to applaud
when Biden simply condemned
the January 6th insurrection
and said nice things
about democracy.
-Two years ago, democracy faced
its greatest threat
since the Civil War and today,
though bruised,
our democracy remains
unbowed and unbroken.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's the face of a guy
who knows that, every time
he claps for Joe Biden,
his phone call from Donald Trump
gets 11 minutes longer.
[ Laughter ]
And, somehow, the ring gets
louder when he calls, too?
[ Nokia ringtone ]
Oh!
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ As McCarthy] Hello, Mr. Trump.
How does he change my ringtone?
[ Laughter ]
You know what? Let me switch
back to my other phone.
-Get one machine, open it up,
and look in there.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Stage whisper ] I knew
calling you back was a mistake,
but I couldn't change
the script.
[ Laughter ]
It was too --
I thought, the first time,
you'd do better and we'd call it
back, but then --
[ Laughter ]
I couldn't signal them to --
So, anyway, it was fine.
You did great both times.
[ Laughter ]
No, we won't be --
[ Laughter fades ]
We won't be needing you
tomorrow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Thudding ]
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
Now, Biden definitely took --
There's no one in there.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mouthing "There was" ]
Now, Biden definitely took some
digs at Republicans, to be sure,
like when he touted his
bipartisan infrastructure bill
and said he'd even fund projects
in districts where Republican
members of Congress voted
against the bill.
-I want to thank
my Republican friends
who voted for the law
and my Republican friends
who voted against it as well.
But I'm still -- I still get
asked to fund the projects
in those districts as well,
but don't worry.
[ Laughter ]
I promised I'd be a president
for all Americans.
-Whoo!
[ Applause ]
-We'll fund these projects
and I'll see you
at the groundbreaking!
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very, very Biden line.
"I'll see you
at the groundbreaking."
[ As Biden ]
I'll shake your hand,
kiss your baby,
I'll give your wife a ride
in my Stingray.
[ Laughter ]
Gonna have a lot of fun.
In fact, Biden really leaned
into economic populism
in his speech,
tackling things the vast
majority of Americans hate,
like absurdly high prices
for insulin,
surprise medical bills,
high concert prices
jacked up by Ticketmaster,
[ Laughter ]
and junk fees
at banks and airlines.
At one point, he even said
he wanted to eliminate
surprise fees at hotels.
-I know how unfair it feels
when a company overcharges you
and gets away with it.
Not anymore.
We've written a bill
to stop it all.
It's called the Junk Fee
Prevention Act.
We're going to ban surprise
resort fees
that hotels charge on your bill.
Those fees can cost
up to $90 a night
at hotels
that aren't even resorts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, you know
Joe Biden has stayed
at a Motel 6,
[ Laughter and applause ]
expecting better accommodation.
[ As Biden ]
These aren't even
resorts, folks.
[ Laughter ]
No water slide, no golf course,
and you got to pay
for the continental breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, those metal chairs
by the pool
give me waffle thighs.
[ Laughter ]
And that focus on economic
populism is what led
to the big moment of the night,
when Biden
called out Republicans
for proposing cuts
to Social Security and Medicare
and threatening to hold
the country hostage
over the debt ceiling,
unless Democrats acquiesce.
It led to a lot
of Republican heckling,
including that moment
we showed you earlier
with Marjorie Taylor Greene.
-Instead of making the wealthy
pay their fair share,
some Republicans --
some Republicans want Medicare
and Social Security to sunset.
I'm not saying it's a majority.
[ Booing ]
Let me give you --
Anybody who doubts it,
contact my office.
I'll give you a copy.
I'll give you a copy
of the proposal.
-You're a liar!
That means Congress
doesn't vote --
[ Shouting ]
-Liar!
-I'm glad to see.
I'm not saying
it's a majority of you.
I don't even think it's even
a significant --
-Don't speak anymore.
[ Shouting ]
-But it's being proposed
by individuals.
I'm politely not naming them,
but it's being proposed
by some of you.
-Okay, first of all,
in a split screen
with these two,
I'm definitely less inclined
to believe the lady
who's dressed
like she's leaving her entire
fortune to her cat.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, that's right,
you can all laugh at me now.
Oh, laugh it on, Marjorie.
But when I go, you get nothing,
nothing, you hear me?
Mr. Poppenscotch,
on the other hand,
will live like a king!
[ Laughter ]
Let's go, Mr. Poppenscotch.
Why are you clawing at me,
you turncoat?
Do you want to stay with them?
Fine!
I'll just bury myself with it!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughing ]
Also, it's generally not
an effective tactic
to debate the one guy
in the room
with a podium and a microphone,
[ Laughter ]
especially when you have
to scream
from the back row
without a microphone.
That was like watching
a rap battle
between Eminem and Shy Ronnie.
[ Laughter ]
"SNL" classic.
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
-♪ Speak up ♪
-When you scream from the back,
you look like a crazy person
yelling at the bus driver
because he refused to drop you
off at the racetrack.
[ Laughter ]
And Greene isn't the only one
who made a big show
of disagreeing with Biden.
There was also
Utah Senator Mike Lee,
who pretended to be
utterly confused
as to what Biden could possibly
be referring to when Biden said
he would not allow the country
to default on its debt,
if Republicans demanded cuts
to safety net programs.
-We're not going to be moved
into being threatened
to default on the debt,
if we don't respond.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Folks.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry, are you
really confused,
or are you just acting like
you're in an episode
of "Curb Your Enthusiasm"?
[ Laughter ]
"You said you would
cut Medicare, Larry!"
[ As Larry ]
Ah...
[ Laughter ]
I don't think I did.
"Yes, you did, Larry!"
Not true, Rosie.
"Yes, it is, you bald [bleep]!"
And...
[ Laughter ]
...in Mike Lee's case,
it would be true
because he campaigned
on eliminating Medicare
and Social Security
when he first ran for Senate
back in 2010.
-Nice!
-Hear, hear.
[ Applause ]
-Um...
[ Tableware clunks, clinks ]
-Sorry.
-I mean, that's an insane thing
to admit on camera
in American politics.
Have you ever been
to a polling place?
Half the people in there are
on their way
to cash a Social Security check.
[ Laughter ]
[ Oldster voice ]
I have two errands.
I guess it's going to be
a nap day.
[ Laughter ]
It's almost as bad
as complaining
about the price of salsa
for your crudité.
[ Laughter ]
Here's my reaction
to finding out
that Mike Lee called, on camera,
for eliminating Social Security.
[ Laughter ]
And he's not the only one.
Senators Rick Scott
and Ron Johnson
both floated plans
that would sunset
Social Security and Medicare
by putting them
up for periodic votes
that would subject them to cuts
and Georgia Republican
Congressman Rick Allen
said he would raise
the retirement age
because, he claims,
people come up to him
and say they want
to work longer.
-Mm-hmm?
-Yeah.
-No, that's wrong.
If people want to work longer,
you don't need to give them
an incentive
because they already want
to do it.
[ Laughter ]
You need incentives for things
people don't want to do,
like [bleep] working longer
[ Laughter ]
because you made that story up.
As far as I can tell,
the only person
who actually wants
to work longer is Joe Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone thought that dude
would hang it up
after he was vice president
at the age of 74,
but he watched Obama do it
and said,
"Hey, I'd like to have
the world's hardest job
and do it into my 80s.
Plus, I hear they bring you
free balloons."
[ Laughter ]
And, honestly,
who can blame Biden
for wanting to stick around,
when these are his opponents?
Biden thrives when compared
to the current era
of Republicans.
Remember, Biden ran
for president twice,
never got close.
Ran against Trump, boom,
he's in the Oval Office.
The beginning of his address
last night
wasn't anything special,
but then these lunatics
started heckling
and you could see him
lick his lips
and everyone thought, "Okay,
Grandpa came to play."
[ Laughter and applause ]
These guys make Biden look like
a Harlem Globetrotter,
even though trotting
isn't exactly his strong suit.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
If only he had Marjorie
Taylor Greene's balloon,
he could've have just floated
up the stairs.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
Biden could not have asked
for a better contrast
than the one he got
last night --
a screaming lady
in a white fur coat
and a party that straight-up
lied about his past support
for cutting
or sunsetting programs
that Americans
overwhelmingly support.
Biden rattled off applause lines
while McCarthy was stone-faced
and Greene stomped her feet
so hard, it was...
-Groundbreaking.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]